اذا اذا توسعنا قليلا في السؤال
الاخير رفح ومبر فيلادلفيا مناطق حساسه
بالنسبه لمصر وسمعنا قاده اسرائيل يتحدثون
كثيرا خاصه عن معبر فيلادلفيا هذا الضغط
الاسرائيلي والاستراتيجيه التي يتبعها في
خانيونس هل تجعل من المواجهه في رفح ومعبر
فيلادلفيا امرا واقعا في المستقبل هذا
يعتمد على قرار مصر هل الدفاع عن حدودها
قرار سياس سيادي ام لا المنطق يقول قرار
سيادي الاماني تقول يجب على مصر ان تفتح
المعبر لانه هذا المعبر في
ارضها وعندما ذه اقيمت الدعوه في لاهاي
ماذا كانت المرافعه الم يقولوا نحن لم
نغلق المعبر وهذا المعبر مسؤوليه مصر
وحملت مصر هذه الكارثه ولو ولو امام
المحكمه
نظريان المنطق يقول لنترك الدم والاخوه
ونتحدث بمنظور انساني يجب ان اتخذ قرار
بالامر بالبعد الاخر كيف اسمح لجيش
الاحتلال ان يسيطر على الجانب الاخر
ويمنعني نعم هناك اتفاقيات كام ديفيد لا
انكرها ولكن تم تعديل اتفاقيه ك كام ديفيد
وسمح للطائرات الاسرائيليه بقصف داخل
سيناء في المنطقه جيم من اجل محاربه
الارهاب توحيد الجهد كما هو يدفع بقواته
عليك ان تحمي حدودك الان عندما نتحدث عن
هذا الشريط في بعض بض مناطقه عرض الشريط
460 متر ما بين
البوابه وما بين السياج هذه المنطقه عمقها
14 14 كيلو و300 متر من السياج الى الرشيد
وهذه الان حبال وا الاوتاد الخيم مشتركه
عبر ه المنطقه هل مصر لهذه الدرجه ستكون
عاجزه عن ان ان تتخذ موقفا يمنع نتنياهو
الذي يقول يجب ان اسيطر عليه ولكن انا انا
السؤال الاستراتيجيه في خانيونس هل هل تشي
لك استراتيجيا بانها تدفع لانه رفح الان
المنطقه الوحيده التي لا يوجد فيها جيش
اسرايل ش جنوب غرب دعنا نكون اكثر تحديدا
جنوب غرب خان يونس ما يطلق
عليها محرره جوش قطيف وال المواصي
وفيلادلفيا هذه المنطقه تعتبر هي على شكل
حرف ال هي المنطقه التي التي يفترض انها
امنه وهي التي استهدفت في صباح هذا اليوم
استهدفت وحتى استهدف من هو يتحرك باتجاه
هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه في لحظه ما قد
يكون فيها اكثر من نصف سكان غزه بمعنى اخر
كما قلت لك اوتاد الخيام مشتركه من السياج
حتى